we are sharing the story of john furna a
woodworker in washington state with an
incredible imagination
his creations are a combination of his
unique outlook on life and his skills
with power tools and by the way uh he's
handling those power tools and doing all
that all else he does uh with one of the
most important things that an artist
needs without one of the most important
things an artist needs jimmy yuka's met
furnace at his home to find out how dark
days in his past help lead to a brighter
future
sound
touch
smell
important senses for anyone who creates
art or appreciates it
john furnis is a washington woodworker
whose wares are handmade in a small shop
adjacent to his home
he's also blind when you are using the
saw and using the lathe you're doing all
that on your own yeah no one's coming in
there to help you nope i have a very
healthy respect
shaded with a bit of fear around the
table saw
the first bowl i made i
i had my finger in a place that it
shouldn't have been
i wasn't paying attention and i got hurt
pretty bad
trail of blood like a wounded cowboy all
the way to the back door the first bowl
you made is actually right behind my
head there's a little bit of blood in
that bowl it's genetically verifiable
that that is my goal
[Laughter]
furnace found his knack for this work
after attending a wood shop class in a
vocational rehab program the biggest
difference between a blind and sighted
woodworker is the way we measure things
he credits memory and imagination for
his ability to adapt how did you become
the blind woodworker i attempted suicide
when i was 16.
luckily i only lost my sight and sense
of smell and my mind and my brain was
left completely intact how have you been
able to turn that and really be as
positive and as happy as you are i've
chosen to laugh at life
so i
left the lawnmower by the back stairs
one time and i did like a a sideways
barrel roll over the top of it
and laughing so hard because the image
of me
doing that goes through my mind so i
i've chosen to to laugh at life as much
as i can furnace now 40 once repaired
pianos at a school for the blind but his
passion shifted after a chance encounter
with a volunteer i was taking a piano
for this fundraiser and i'm sitting in
this room you know painting and john
walks in he puts his hand on the wet
paint on the piano and so it was like
kind of like a meat cute i got up the
nerve to ask him out first he said hey
why don't we go pick peas at my
community garden plot it was the most
romantic first date i'd ever been on and
three years later we got married in the
same spot annie knew
that my talents and my passion really
laid with woodwork so she bought me a
lathe lathe workers a lot of times are
called turners and so this is kathleen
turner
but just below the surface of his
ever-present smile the lingering pain of
his past what is getting you so
emotional right now
oh just give me a second
you got it
i don't know why it's hitting me so hard
this year
the anniversary of my attempt was
summoned
on the 10th
the couple takes a trip to the ocean
every year to reflect on the moment that
took his sight but not his life we try
to do something special
to celebrate that the fact that he's
still here yeah you know but
that he was given a second chance a
second chance to build this bond
a business
and a brand
what's with the name i don't know i just
i've always had kind of a quirky sense
of humor
and so
you know the blind woodsman
the blind woodsman is an online store
where the furnaces sell john's
functional works of art he runs the
tools she runs the business
you have almost two million people now
following you on tick tock hey sweetie
how's it going honeybee good what's the
feedback you get people are really
inspired by a few things they're
inspired by john's
story incredible story and then they're
inspired by our
love what you working on i just got done
with this bowl here i read somewhere you
said
i lost my sight to gain my vision yes
yes i truly believe that i really over
the years have come to
the belief that i am supposed to be
blind that's something that
i needed to have to become the man i am
there we go for cbs mornings jamie yukas
washougal washington
wow yeah that's powerful big wow on many
levels i think i lost my sight to gain
my vision i love the two of them
together hi sweetie hi honeybees
i'm fascinated that he can do that work
with and working with a saw and that
equipment yeah and not being able to
it's such a good reminder that
everything hard in your life made you
who you are now and you can't throw any
bit out and still be who you are so his
appreciation for the difficulty on his
path and how he feels he always was
meant to be where he is right now is
important and think about that like he
can't see but he found a love of his
life he found passion and he found
purpose right like that's deep it is
deep